[Music]
I'm Alexa nice to meet you
[Laughter]
I know this kind of goes for I guess
well I got a girl oh my god dude has a
girlfriend
[Music]
:
I do feel map everybody please welcome
Alexa okay
I saw my face and I'm like Oh God
hi my name is Alexa and I was in ten
versus one oh my god okay so someone put
it on Twitter and then that got I think
20 million views and of course I got
flooded with the Indians of people
saying that they were singled and that I
should date them it's I don't remember
the beginning I only remember the end so
a little little nervous about what I
said I'm Alexa nice to meet you
just like Amazon huh I get that so often
I'm just glad it's like that thing I can
buy yo Alexa play to this song I'm gonna
pause it because I still get so much hey
Alexa how's the weather like all this
stuff it's so annoying please don't do
that I'm pretty good about picking up
inflections of like voices and
everything and I can tell if somebody's
being honest with me or not by their
voice oh my god that was the worst case
of foreshadowing if I've ever seen it so
tell me a little about yourself what do
you what do you do right now I'm a
full-time student I I'm actually really
into airplanes you like I need someone
who can like twerk you know like and you
need someone who can tour you're saying
about twerking and everything I haven't
tried it so I don't know if I can do it
that is a lie I say I haven't tried
twerking that's because I knew my mom
was gonna watch this but mom sorry a
girl can talk for me something that's
really important
I'm trying to become a pilot and I've
joined the Navy to try and he said he's
trying to become a pilot and he joined
the Navy I don't think that makes it
does that make sense because the Navy
isn't that votes oh wait there's there's
planes on I don't know I'm a musician
actor but I'm also studying political
science and I want to be President of
the United States so I wants to be
President so what's the hardest thing
that you've ever been through and how
did you get through it
yeah that's hard it's our uniquely today
one of the hardest things I've had to go
through I struggled with a lot of
depression and self-confidence
I'm starting to love myself I'm super
outgoing and I help people so helping
people help yeah yeah that's amazing I
feel like that super deep question
although I did really want to answer it
I kinda shouldn't have I wasn't
comfortable talking about it but since
then I'm a lot more comfortable about
everything don't get me wrong I still
have depression but as far as the DMS go
I did get a lot of DM saying that they
were happy that I talked about my
depression and I actually still talked
to one of the people that DM to me
asking for help so just that alone
really helps me I think I have a
decision all right so I'm gonna have to
go with Joseph I want someone who I'm
not looking for but I can also be super
serious with oh poor Alex he's so
surprised he's like oh you can tell he
did not want to be picked I didn't
really envision you looking like
anything my heart is racing I know it's
gonna happen and yeah
don't please kind of go somewhere I
guess well I got a girl club what thing
I was really good you're awesome you're
awesome though oh I do
I haven't actually watched like Oh God
and all of that just came back and oh my
goodness I love the only one that does
though here why are you guys really oh
dang I told my girlfriend like all about
and everything and she said it sounds a
bit cool cuz I totally went into this
thinking that I was gonna end up with
somebody who is single and like looking
but I mean I'm not hurt or anything I'm
just kind of confused as to why he was
he said I'm not hurt and I was really
hurt
I was really hurt who by the end of this
that's initially when I first saw him I
was really happy because like I said he
was cute like he's attractive but as
soon as he said I had a girl it took me
a second to register and then when it
fully registered my heart just like sake
cuz I thought I was gonna walk out of
here with like someone who may have
turned into like my boyfriend but I
think it just kind of showed me that not
everyone's who they seem
I yeah I'm just a lot more cautious
overall with relationships now would you
be willing to call Joseph right now and
see how he's doing I don't have his
number unfortunately I know you do yes
sure yeah
hello hi it's Alexa I don't know if you
remember me do you mind if we FaceTime
instead he's been so confused he's like
huh what I'm not that good hi I'm good
how are you I'm great
are you still with that girl that you
were with at the time I can say no cuz
uh that's like the famous line is I got
a girl I'm good overall um because of
that video I ended up getting a
boyfriend but it didn't end up working
out so yeah one of the people that slide
in we're actually or slidden we're
actually successful so that's weird but
yeah other than that it's been like the
same old you know you get with somebody
sometimes it works out sometimes it does
it I think that doesn't really change
the fact that you're a cool person and
that it really boils down to the fact
that who you are really shines through
and whether people like that or not or
they can appreciate it or not you know
you just got to keep trucking along and
you gotta just keep being yourself like
this way honestly so yeah I've gotten I
got like the United ladies like truth
thank you thank you so much you're cool
too I know I'm happy we aren't like
hating each other or anything yeah of
course we'll definitely catch up in
everything now that I have your number
yeah you too bye I see y'all that was
cool
I think he's gonna pick up I forgot how
well like we actually were able to hold
conversations between us so that was
really nice I don't think anybody will
anymore but don't give Joseph hate or
thing because I know he got a lot of
like death threats even it's not that
serious I got rejected it's okay
everything's fine it happens
mine just happened to be recorded and
put on the Internet
overall I really think that this just
helped me love myself overall even
though I did end up getting rejected it
kind of flipped and showed me how much I
really deserve and how many people out
there really think that like I deserve
the world and more so it kind of it gave
me a really good picture about what I
deserve